[Música]
hoy quiero contarles algo que me sucedió
algunos años atrás estaba yo en la
ciudad de quito haciendo un evento
enorme más de 10.000 personas de 19
países cuatro idiomas en traducción
simultánea al mismo tiempo tres días de
evento
es el evento y yo era la productora
general del evento y acá los productores
no me van a dejar mentir que hasta que
no apagamos la luz y se va el último de
los invitados nosotros no descansamos
estaba con esta mochila de tres vías
agotadas física y mentalmente literal no
daba más contaba los minutos para que
termine el evento ya sabía que subía el
vicepresidente a hablar y que después
lanzaba mi gran show así que yo ya me
veía en el hotel descansando después de
tres días de haber dormido cuatro horas
cada día
y no saben lo que me pasa
de pronto en sus palabras dice bueno y
esta producción maravillosa y yo quiero
invitar a wendy wunder la productora
general a que suba el escenario que hizo
wendy wunder se escondió
literal qué vergüenza lo cuento ya
porque ya lo digerido pero me escondí me
escondí y después me pare y de pronto
estaba yo ahí petrificada hice un
flashback a un evento de algunos años
antes de similar envergadura así como
este donde el escenario de a 360 y el
principal expositor era nada más y nada
menos que
antonio bis
recuerdo claramente cuando lo tenía en
frente primero porque mide dos metros
nosotros lo tenía al frente y yo decía
el seguridad de energía una pasión para
entrar al escenario y yo estaba aquí
parado así que no podía ni subir porque
decía tenía yo sé que voy a hacer no
tengo un power point me miraba las
zapatillas me miraba el teaser que decía
producción que he dicho hacia el paso a
ginés solo de usado todo el día así que
las condiciones no eran favorables
entonces decía qué hago por donde corro
donde me escondo hago así desde abajo y
no subo pero le insistía la gente empezó
a gritar web y wendy y en el minuto que
empezaron a gritar
se levantaron todos mis barrotes
imaginarios todos los que se puedan
imaginar yo estaba como mogín ayesa de
quiénes mogín y levanten la mano si
saben no cuenta alguien sabe quiénes
mojinos la historia mogín y no la sabe
ya
boeing y molinero un tigre blanco
espectacular y es vendido que le regala
el gobierno de la india al presidente
eisenhower en la década de 1960 este
tigre de un ejemplar maravilloso así que
decidieron construir un recinto
espectacular para que él estuviera en su
hábitat natural pero de pronto que pasó
mohib y tuvo que estar un tiempo muchos
meses en una jaula con barrotes de
hierro y suelo de cemento caminaba de
derecha a izquierda como yo acá con el
circulito que no me puedo mover no
entonces terminada de derecha a
izquierda de derecha a izquierda pero
así estuvo muchísimos meses hasta que le
construyeron su espectacular recinto
llegó el gran día todo el pueblo de
washington estaba ahí para ver a este
ejemplar salir y saben qué pasó
abrieron la jaula imagine y se dirigió
directamente un muro perimetral donde
empezó a caminar en su jaula imaginaria
de 4 x 3 de derecha a izquierda derecha
izquierda por el resto de suya
yo era mogín y ahí está este es el
verdadero mogín y es el azúcar se
imaginaria todos vivimos nuestra vida
dentro de un espacio mental creado en
nuestro nuestro subconsciente en nuestro
inconsciente y nos pueden jugar muy
malas pasadas y de hecho a mí me la
estaba jugando porque me di cuenta que
es alguien sé lo que es la glosó fobia
los o fobia hoy hoy los agarre con todas
las lecciones fuera el avión la glosó
fobia es el temor a hablar en público
el primer temor que existe en el mundo
es a la muerte y el segundo
hablar en público estar aquí parado lo
que han hecho todos los speakers que
hemos estado acá créanme que se necesita
coraje no importa cuánta cancha y
cuántos años lo hayas hecho se necesita
coraje para estar acá da temor según la
universidad de california el 75% de las
personas tienen miedo a hablar en
público imagínense eso y en mi defensa
tengo otra cosa para decir el ser humano
produce 60 mil pensamientos al día 60
mil etc un numerito con el celular 60
mil pensamientos al día y el 89 por
ciento de ellos son negativos y nunca
suceden es decir salimos a la calle
empezamos me va agarrar el hobby no me
van a robar no olvide la plata no recoge
mi mamá el niño no hizo la tarea y
vivimos así si todo el rato repitiendo
repitiendo cosas que nunca nos van a
suceder
y entonces en mi medio ahí yo para
verificar con el pie uno quería avanzar
les cuento que en verdad si uno quería
avanzar porque era mi momento soñado yo
después de haber visto anthony robbins
decía yo quiero algún día hacer speaker
yo quiero algún día tener valor y
pararme en un escenario como el no sé si
tan imponente pero al menos para ver el
escenario y hablar algo decente
yo nací en un circo en el circo tihany
ese mismo crimen nací y viví hasta los 7
años de edad en un mundo maravilloso un
lugar mágico un lugar que yo llamo un
lugar extraordinario en este lugar es
cosas mágicas suceden a mí me encantaba
desde chica pararme en la puerta y ver
como la gente entraba a esto que yo
llamaba la máquina de hacer felices a
las personas y estaba convencida que el
circo era un portal un portal mágico en
el cual la gente entraba de una forma
triste preocupada convocada a veces como
deprimida no a ver si esto me divierte y
de pronto iba viendo las caras así como
entre los mire viéndole las caras cuando
iban viendo no sé el show de trapecio el
triple o cuádruple salto mortal para
caer en una varita de 3 centímetros de
distancia imagínense los años que esos o
más
yo sentía que mis artistas del circo
eran como velas encendidas no pasa no
importaba el tamaño
ellos salían a llenar este espacio con
calor con mucha luz y con mucho amor
habían dedicado una vida entera a hacer
que la gente sea más feliz y yo me
pregunto
cómo sería la vida si todos nos
dedicáramos a ser más felices a otras
personas si cada persona que tiene un
contacto con nosotros dice qué chévere
sin embargo muchas veces somos velas
derretidas de las caminando por el mundo
dejándonos por todo por la mascarilla
por el sol porque llovió porque hace
calor porque hace frío vivimos siempre
en constante queja y pesimismo
ahí está samba uno de los más mágicos de
mi vida fue el día que puede presenciar
el nacimiento de mi elefantita samba
tenía yo cuatro años y medio ese día la
vida me cambió les juro que me cambio
entregué yo una conexión que fue
inmediata pero el momento que más
recuerdo fue cuando ya había pasado con
un año samba ya pesaba como 700 kilos y
yo 15 y mi papá me dijo bueno hoy te
toca aprender a montar la samba y estaba
como horita como ese día en el escenario
como papá no está seguro si hoy vas a
montar las ambos lo primero que me
pregunto es quién domina el jinete o el
elefante a lo que yo rápidamente
contesté papá
el elefante se quiere salir corriendo de
la carpa me va a llevar porque yo te voy
a hacer
mi papá me de una elección que se me
quedó grabada a pesar de mi corta edad
me dijo no importa el tamaño de este
jinete lo que importa es la confianza en
sí mismo la determinación y la pericia o
habilidad
así que dicho esto aprendí a montar
elefantes
la verdad es que una conexión
maravillosa muchos años después pero
muchísimos años después realmente
entendí lo que mi papá me quería decir
con esto siendo minas y el jinete o el
elefante y en realidad me encontré con
un libro es espectacular que se llama la
hipótesis de la felicidad de jonathan
jair y jonathan jair justamente hace una
analogía entre el jinete y el elefante
quien es el jinete es el lado racional
es este lado reflexivo el que planifica
y que evalúa pros y contras el que
analiza las situaciones mientras que el
elefante pues es el lado emocional el
que quiere las cosas ahora no es el que
se maneja por las emociones sino le
cuenten cuentos que se hoy no quiero
hacer algo no lo hago y acá les voy a
preguntar a ver si está si me la
responden porque ella bando fenosa
alguien le ha pasado que es un jinete
los lunes les ha dicho voy a empezar la
dieta y el elefante del mar que se come
chocolate levanten la mano
me incluyo incluyo pero básicamente es
eso también puedo poner otros ejemplos
como el gimnasio en fin hay una variedad
infinita en las cuales nuestro jinete va
para allá y el elefante pues va para el
otro lado entonces el reto está en saber
poner a nuestro jinete en nuestro
elefante del mismo lado porque les
cuento que la fuerza de voluntad tiene
un límite por eso cuando vamos
envejeciendo tenemos una fuerza de
voluntad se los voy diciendo de una vez
la fuerza de voluntad tiene un límite y
el jinete no le podrá ganar al elefante
si no se ponen de acuerdo y esto no es
una tarea fácil ahora si bien es cierto
nos hemos referido a nuestro elefante
con nuestro lado emocional como un lado
poco reflexivo y hace poco juicioso en
él habitan también el temor el rencor
la duda pero también hábil habita en
virtudes espectaculares como el amor la
pasión la compasión y la lealtad
nosotros somos quien tenemos que decidir
cuál es en esas virtudes
queremos utilizar pero depende de
nosotros siempre en con relación y bueno
hablando a nuestros objetivos porque
para tener la razón si yo tengo mi razón
y el corazón alineados voy a lograr mi
objetivo les quiero contar otra anécdota
que también es 100% verdad también por
es por los cinco años se habrán dado
cuenta que es un poquito traviesa yo
quería ser anita vargas que era la
equilibrista decir cosa yo soñaba con
ser equilibrista y a partir de los dos
años había empezado a caminar a
distintas alturas 20 centímetros 30 50 y
ya me sentía totalmente empoderada y un
día
y que habían dejado la cuerda floja
después de un ensayo dije esta es la mía
y me trepé subí y empecé a caminar como
me viene enseñado como yo ya sabía
visión adelante brazos abiertos junta
talón junta talones seguir avanzando
derechito sin mirar abajo sin mirar a
los costados bien enfocada sin embargo
en la mitad del camino me di cuenta que
la sobera mucho más larga de lo que yo
pensaba y sentía como que la va a ser un
chicle que cada vez iba más lejos y me
empezó a dar el temor y era chica era
muy chica una voz me empezó a hablar me
decía web y tú puedes tuya se ha
ensayado esto ya lo has logrado faltan
un par de pasitos de estas en si estás
asustado por las curas sigue adelante
por supuesto llegué al otro lado y vi a
mi imagen bajo la escalera llorando pero
emocionada porque ya veía mi cartel no
niña de 5 años cruza la cuerda floja' yo
ya era famosa hable cumplió ese objetivo
por supuesto llegué abajo en la que
estaba era mi mamá nunca más cambian en
la cuerda floja
y bueno la que había estado hablando me
desde la mitad porque salí a buscar a
esta niña para la hora de almuerzo de
pronto se da cuenta que su hija está a
siete metros de alto caminando y medio
empezó a decir reina qué bien lo haces
tú puedes y él sigue adelante tú lo vas
a lograr y me di cuenta que si yo seguía
repitiendo me las cosas negativas que yo
les va a hacer así va a ser mi vida
siempre
pero igual aquí estaba me he pasado la
vida preguntándome qué hace que unas
personas sean más exitosas o más
extraordinarias o que brillen con esa
luz como mis velas encendidas porque yo
durante muchos años me sentí muy
avergonzada de haber vivido en el
circuito quiero confesar yo es más hasta
hace muy pocos años recién conté esta
historia
no fue fácil cuando dejé el circuito que
quiera vivir al mundo de los
encarrilados como llamaba yo a las
personas que van de un lado al otro sin
mirar por la ventana si se ponen a
pensar en el colegio yo era la niña loca
que no podía dar la dirección de su casa
porque había vivido en un camper nómade
y dibuja a mi casa con rueditas y decía
que mi mascota era un elefante se
imaginarán en el colegio realmente era
la loca nadie me invitaba un cumpleaños
dije es la primera vez que entro
cumpleaños mi mamá me dijo hija lo único
que yo te pido es que pases
desapercibida es lo único que te pido y
bueno obviamente me dejé llevar por una
canción y terminé bailando como las
bailarinas del circo con la pierna acá
nunca voy a olvidar porque tenía un
vestido celeste y mi mamá que me agarró
de la oreja y me sacó dijo que parte de
pasa desapercibida no entendiste
mientras que mi papá por otro lado que
era un búlgaro inmigrante volaba aviones
me decía que yo había nacido para
brillar así que en estos dos mundos
crecimos al medio y esto es lo que hay
pero seguía petrificado no me podía
mover y me llamaban del escenario y era
este estadio y de pronto
empecé a pensar en lo que les decía como
despierto yo ese ser extraordinario
logro el éxito que yo me propongo y aquí
mi fórmula si yo al niño en la razón y
la emoción que son y jinete con el
elefante voy a tener un objetivo pero no
necesariamente lo voy a tener a largo
plazo o de la forma que yo quiero yo
tengo que multiplicarlo por la visión de
túnez que es esa determinación de
avanzar a pesar del temor 100 por ciento
enfocado un día delante del otro sin
distraernos sin mirar abajo sin mirar al
costado sin mirar a ningún lado con
determinación como les decía confianza
en uno mismo y pericia y eso para mí
exponencia cualquier cosa ahora tengamos
claro que el éxito en la vida se mide
para todos nosotros
de una manera diferente
porque todos usamos métricas distintas y
yo pongo a bill gates acá con la madre
teresa de calcuta paul es más exitoso
pues cada uno en lo que cree que es el
éxito en la vida y eso nadie más lo
puede medir por ti así que bueno les red
mi fórmula que me ha tomado años y bueno
se preguntarán cómo acabó el cuento de
de quito
cuando les dijo que tenía el look de
trapeador
díganme que no es
veo esta foto y ya solo para usted dice
acá no sale
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en la única forma de aprender si yo me
encargo de la de su dieta
[Música]
lo intentamos
pero si yo te cae en el riego voy a
prender a bancarse esto tengo una vez
y ese es un breve resumen de los demás
30 minutos porque no quería bajar del
escenario y la gente seguía pidiéndome
que les cuente historias del circo tengo
muchas más pero son para otra charla y
bueno ahí está la glosó fóbica con temor
a hablar en público que tuvo que vencer
sus barrotes imaginarios sin tener un
speech para improvisar y dije en verdad
el suelo no pasamos
a veces realmente tenemos temor de
lanzar hacemos nuestras cosas pero les
juro que el suelo no pasamos y el tiempo
se me está yendo a estrés sé observador
no sean como mogi ni abran la mente
abran el corazón y deán es el lugar
espectacular que tienen para
desarrollarse
al ir en la razón y el corazón el jinete
y el elefante en una misma dirección
propongan solo todos los días no
descansen hasta lograr sus objetivos
sigan para adelante
para allá
tengan un objetivo claro apliquen la
visión de túnel con determinación
avancen a pesar del ruido avancen que
nada los detenga nada y sean
responsables de su felicidad porque el
chapulín colorado' no va a venir la
cenicienta tampoco aunque te amen a
quien me ayude quién podrá defenderme
son solo ustedes sus propios sirves y
responsables de su felicidad salgan a
brillar a irradiar calor a dar lo mejor
de sí a dar amor y los dejo con esta
pregunta
en nuestro espacio mental una pequeña
jaula de hierro y cemento como la de
mojinos o es un mundo abierto y extenso
a la aventura y al descubrimiento
como en el circo
[Aplausos]